on this sunny day in tunis thousands
came out to protest against their
president
they were responding to a call for
action from a group known as citizens
against the coup
they believe president kai saeed broke
the law by suspending parliament and
sacking the prime minister in july and
they want him to step down
the future in tunisia is really scary to
me
for now we don't know what are we
gonna have as an institution we don't
have a parliament
we don't have
democracy in our country i am really
scared
protesters used a familiar chant the
people want the removal of the president
they also urge security forces to remain
neutral in this constitutional crisis
many support anahda the largest block in
the suspended parliament
situation is very critical and it is
time for mr kaiser to start listening to
the people and sitting on the table and
getting a
dialogue with those who are living with
him in this country mr kaisaid is there
because he is the president of tunisian
republic so he is president of all
tunisians not only of those who are
there to support him president kai syed
is now ruling by decree after assuming
nearly all executive power he's pledged
to fight corruption and revive a long
stagnant economy he's defended his move
saying it was to save the country but
his critics call it a coup
and while saeed broke ground by
appointing the first female prime
minister he's yet to provide a road map
out of this crisis and she's yet to name
a government
a week ago it was the president's
supporters who were on this very street
endorsing the policies and power grab so
many are against
thousands rallied in tunis and other
cities according to interior ministry
figures yet saeed was filmed telling his
prime minister designate that 1.8
million had turned out nationwide to
back him
the discrepancy is perhaps a reflection
of how divided tunisia has become
andrew chappelle al jazeera